[Musica]
nel 2007
economica ha colpito duramente
l'economia mondiale è anche il mio
lavoro di ingegnere improvvisamente
mancavano i soldi e non riuscivo a
capire perché che per un ingegnere non è
una cosa semplice da accettare
siccome però avevo più tempo a
disposizione mi sono messo a studiare da
dove arrivano i soldi che è un argomento
tabù perché non ne parla nessuno
fino al 2006 l'edilizia andava alla
grande e se volevi comprare una casa le
banche ti davano tutto il denaro che
volevi ma quando è arrivata nel 2007
2008 la crisi finanziaria dei mutui sub
prime
improvvisamente le banche non prestavano
più niente e i soldi sembravano
scomparsi
è come se nella struttura di un edificio
ed è un pilastro
l'edificio crolla analogamente la
struttura portante del sistema economico
è la moneta
se manca anche l'economia crolla se
vogliamo risolvere il problema
inutile girarci intorno servono i soldi
ma dove si trovano il denaro non cresce
sugli alberi
il denaro non si trova sotto terra il
denaro si crea dal nulla
lo ha ammesso anche mario draghi quando
era presidente della banca centrale
europea
il giornalista gli ha chiesto la bce può
mai finire soldi
beh tecnicamente no ha risposto non
possono finire i soldi abbiamo ampie
risorse per far fronte a tutte le nostre
emergenze ma è nostre emergenze di chi
fino ad oggi i soldi sono stati creati
per banche mercati finanziari non per
l'economia reale
in italia abbiamo emergenze da anni
dobbiamo adeguare la sanità alle nuove
malattie dobbiamo ricostruire interi
paesi distrutti dal terremoto
dobbiamo sistemare strade ponti che
crollano dobbiamo fare manutenzione del
territorio per evitare frane ed
alluvioni stampando soldi risolveremo
tutte le nostre emergenze ma che può
creare moneta
oggi ci risponde aristotele che piu di
duemila anni fa aveva già capito che la
moneta è uno strumento convenzionale è
un mezzo di scambio nato per soddisfare
il bisogno infatti in greco moneta si
dice nomisma che viene da nomos
legge perché solo uno stato che fa le
leggi può creare moneta in nome e per
conto del popolo a era talmente vero che
sulle monete ad atene c'era la scritta
degli ateniesi perché avevano capito che
in una democrazia
la moneta appartiene al popolo che la
usa qual è oggi allora la situazione ma
non è mica cambiata tanto l'articolo 1
della nostra costituzione dice che
l'italia è ancora una repubblica
democratica fondata sul lavoro ma la
sovranità di cui quella monetaria era
più importante appartiene ancora al
popolo e quindi a tutti noi
e l'articolo 117 ribadisce che lo stato
ha legislazione esclusiva sulla moneta e
sul sistema tributario cioè le tasse
perché queste due cose sono strettamente
collegate
se io posso imporre le tasse e posso
anche decidere con quale moneta le tasse
le devi pagare addirittura se lo stato
vuole far pagare a cittadini aziende le
tasse deve prima aver creato il denaro
averlo immesso nell'economia e solo dopo
può pretendere il pagamento delle tasse
non può avvenire il contrario lo stato
oggi come ad atene e mette ancora la
propria moneta
anche con l'euro infatti le monete che
abbiamo in tasca hanno una faccia che è
uguale per tutte l'altra faccia è
diversa per ogni nazione
la germania a l'aquila imperiale la
francia ha la scritta liberté égalité
fraternité la spagna al volto del re ma
l'italia ha l'uomo vitruviano di
leonardo è un piccolo simbolo una r una
isola poste che sono le iniziali di
repubblica italiana addirittura i paesi
dell'eurozona possono coniare monete
superiori a 2 euro da 5 da 10 euro che
hanno validità sul loro territorio
l'italia addirittura ha messo la scritta
repubblica italiana per esteso
perché la moneta appartiene allo stato e
ai cittadini che la usano chi emette
moneta ha diritto a ricevere quello che
si chiama signoraggio che l'insieme dei
redditi derivanti dall'emissione
monetaria ma il signoraggio viene da
aggio del signore che è il guadagno del
sovrano
re dello stato infatti nelle monete
metalliche emessi dallo stato il
signoraggio viene percepito direttamente
dallo stato ma chi percepisce il
signoraggio sulle banconote emesse dalla
banca centrale europea ma sempre lo
stato per il cielo dice la banca
d'italia che nel suo sito scrive oggi il
signoraggio viene percepito in prima
battuta dalle banche centrali
le quali tuttavia lo riversano poi agli
stati titolari ultimi della sovranità
monetaria ma se la moneta e la nostra
perché la prendiamo in prestito lo stato
può creare non sono le monete metalliche
ma anche la versione cartacea delle
monete metalliche sono i biglietti di
stato come le vecchie 500 lire può
creare anche moneta elettronica in base
all'articolo 114 bis del testo unico
bancario ma può creare anche moneta
virtuale basata sulla tecnologia block
chain come stanno facendo ormai quasi
tutti nel mondo
la cosa fondamentale è che lo stato ha
una particolarità alla moneta che crea
gli può dare un valore che nessun altro
può dare in un territorio quello
dell'accettazione per il pagamento delle
tasse
però allora gli esperti direbbero se
stampa soldi lo stato crea inflazione ma
è vera questa cosa se io solo in un
deserto e stampo soldi
e ovvio che avrò infrazione perché non
posso aumentare la quantità di beni e
servizi prodotti ma se io sono il
territorio come il nostro dove ci sono
piccole e medie imprese ci sono famiglie
operose risorse da valorizzare
se io stampo soldi aumento la produzione
dei beni e servizi non dei prezzi
lo dice anche la formula di fiches e che
da più di 100 anni definisce la
relazione tra massa monetaria e prezzi
se io aumento la massa monetaria i
prezzi aumentano solo se la velocità di
circolazione e la quantità di beni
prodotti e scambiati è costante ma
questo vale solo se c'è piena
occupazione e capacità produttiva
utilizzata al cento per cento in italia
noi abbiamo disoccupazione del 10 per
cento capacità produttiva non utilizzata
al 30 per cento
se io aumenta la massa monetaria aumenta
la quantità di beni prodotti e scambiati
non certo dei prezzi ma lo si vede anche
dal grafico dell'inferno
che da più di 40 anni scende in
continuazione
questo perché con l'automazione noi
siamo in grado di produrre molti più
beni e servizi ma con sempre meno
occupati la disoccupazione però riduce
la quantità di moneta in circolazione e
questo produce un calo dei consumi è un
calo dei prezzi
bisogna che lo stato in meta più soldi
all'interno dell'economia è ma gli
esperti dicono che lo stato è come una
famiglia
nel bilancio deve stare attenti alle
entrate le uscite ma siamo sicuri che
così lo stato è colui che stampa i soldi
non è come una famiglia se noi vogliamo
equiparare lo stato ha una famiglia
dobbiamo dare alla famiglia una
stampante per i soldi ma allora vedremo
questa scena e tutte le famiglie
italiane e avremmo certamente troppa
moneta in circolazione è lo stato che
deve creare moneta e garantire
un'adeguata quantità in circolazione
allora gli esperti dicono che lo stato
deve restituire il debito pubblico ma
perché lo stato è indebitato pensate
quanto assurdo noi siamo l'unica specie
vivente al mondo che appena nati
siamo già gravati dal debito pubblico ma
noi siamo mica la specie più
intelligente lo stato invece che
stamparli soldi li prende da noi
cittadini aziende attraverso le tasse e
contributi
ma se non gli basta li prende in
prestito dai mercati finanziari
la domanda che ci dovremmo fare ma lui
ei mercati finanziari dove prendiamo la
moneta che diamo lo stato chi la crea la
moneta il denaro non è come l'acqua che
esiste già in natura il denaro per
esistere deve essere creato da qualcuno
allora chi crea il denaro oggi lo stato
abbiamo detto crea le monete metalliche
e ovviamente moneta positiva cioè e
moneta che non deve essere restituita a
qualcuno ma sono solo lo 0 3 per cento
di tutta la moneta che usiamo il resto è
moneta a debito perchè la banca centrale
europea e mette le banconote le presta
al sistema bancario che le utilizza per
creare moneta elettronica bancaria che
insieme le banconote costituisce il 99,7
per cento di tutta la moneta che usiamo
ma cosa succede a un sistema economico
che usa una moneta che viene prestata e
poi deve essere restituita con gli
interessi quindi genera sempre debito è
come un corpo che ha bisogno di sangue
ma noi glielo prestiamo e poi io lo
prendiamo indietro con gli interessi
il corpo muore dissanguato alla stessa
maniera
un sistema economico che ha bisogno di
moneta se questa moneta viene prestata
dal sistema bancario e dalle mercati
finanziari e dobbiamo restituirla con
gli interessi ovviamente aumenterà sia
il debito pubblico che il debito privato
ma il debito non sarà mai azzerato
perché è matematico
la moneta prestata è sempre inferiore al
debito che si genera quindi il debito è
matematicamente inestinguibile se
vogliamo risolvere il problema dobbiamo
fare in modo che lo stato crei molta più
moneta positiva la spenda nell'economia
questa moneta può circolare liberamente
non deve essere restituita a nessuno poi
lo stato la preleverà attraverso le
tasse ma se vogliamo arricchire la
popolazione cioè tutti noi dobbiamo fare
in modo che la spesa sia sempre maggiore
delle tasse che vengono prelevate è
matematico noi siamo come questa bella
macchina sportiva con un motore
potentissimo ma dobbiamo spingere la
mano perché non abbiamo la benzina
ma vi rendete conto oggi la crisi
economica è essenzialmente una crisi per
mancanza di soldi soldi che si possono
creare con un click del computer
i cittadini hanno problemi di
finanziamento a causa delle tasse della
disoccupazione delle disuguaglianze
causate dalle speculazioni finanziarie
le imprese hanno problemi di
finanziamento a causa del credit crunch
cioè del fatto che le banche italiane
ormai sono in mano straniera e prestano
sempre meno all'economia reale lo stato
ha problemi di finanziamento a causa del
debito pubblico del costo degli
interessi e dei ricatti dei mercati
finanziari con lo spread
noi abbiamo creato e progettato un piano
da 1.000 miliardi in due anni che
risolverebbe tutti i problemi
in questa maniera lo stato può creare
nuova moneta digitale
il pieno rispetto dei trattati europei
che permetterà di finanziare i cittadini
di finanziare le imprese e di finanziare
la spesa pubblica dello stato
vediamo queste soluzioni una per una per
finanziare i cittadini serve una moneta
fiscale che è una moneta positiva perché
non genera debito
sostanzialmente è un credito d'imposta
che lo stato può creare air i due è
utile essere utilizzato dai cittadini
per ridurre le tasse future
ma fin da subito può essere utilizzato
per scambiarselo tra di noi praticamente
come un sistema di pagamento questo
credito da quando le abbiamo proposto
nelle sedi istituzionali è stato già
implementato con il dl il rilancio del
2020 che è il famoso super bonus che
permette ai cittadini di ristrutturare
la propria casa di abitazione
praticamente a costo zero perché per che
riceviamo è a fronte dei lavori
effettuati un credito d'imposta che
superiori all'importo dei lavori con
questo credo possiamo ridurre le tasse
future ma possiamo anche cederlo ad
altri e addirittura delle banche per
avere moneta in euro in cambio
questa manovra permetterà allo stato di
aumentare la spesa pubblica senza fare
debito
l'altra soluzione è finanziare l'impresa
attraverso delle banche pubbliche che
non facciano speculazioni sui mercati
finanziari le banche pubbliche possono
fare nuovi prestiti all'economia reale
possono ricevere prestiti a tasso
negativo dalla bce ma possono
soprattutto acquistare titoli dello
stato permettendo di risparmiare gli
interessi perché lo stato li pagherebbe
alla sua banca pubblica cioè a se stesso
noi abbiamo già una banca pubblica che è
il mediocredito centrale che potrebbe
diventare come la kfw tedesca
ricordiamo che la germania all'inizio
della crisi del co vide ha immesso
nell'economia attraverso il suo sistema
bancario pubblico che è più del 50 per
cento del totale
820 miliardi di euro e che noi potremmo
creare alla stessa stregua se avessimo
il sistema bancario pubblico l'ultima
manovra la più importante è quella che
permette allo stato di finanziarsi non
con i mercati finanziari ma con i conti
di risparmio in italia chi ha dai
risparmi o li mette nel conto
e lo gli fruttano niente o li investe
sui mercati finanziari
però mette a rischio il proprio capitale
ma se diamo i soldi alla banca o ai
mercati finanziari questi li utilizzano
per fare speculazione sui mercati anche
con i titoli dello stato ma allora tanto
vale che prestiamo noi direttamente allo
stadio ma ci deve mettere lo stato a
disposizione uno strumento nuovo un
conto corrente di risparmio dove se io
deposito soldi o il capitale garantito o
una remunerazione buona ma addirittura
posso trasferire valori da un conto
corrente all'altro come un vero e
proprio strumento di pagamento
in questo modo il debito pubblico
diventerebbe moneta in questa maniera
possiamo attrarre una parte cospicua
della ricchezza finanziaria gli italiani
che ricordo è più di 4mila miliardi di
euro ed evitare quell'assurdità che
questa ricchezza è prevalentemente
investita sui mercati finanziari
quindi andiamo noi a finanziare con i
nostri soldi l'economia di altre nazioni
non è più possibile andare avanti così
il piano da 1.000 miliardi di euro in
due anni è reso possibile da un
innovazione tecnologica la realizzazione
di una piattaforma elettronica integrata
che permette di gestire il conto
corrente fiscale il conto corrente
bancario pubblico e il conto corrente di
risparmio questa gestione può essere
semplificata attraverso l'utilizzo di
un'unica carta magnetica che permette ai
cittadini di gestire le proprie finanze
in maniera gratuita e semplice cosa ci
facciamo con mille miliardi
mi ripetono spesso e mi chiedono in
realtà la prima cosa che dobbiamo fare è
risolvere tutte le nostre emergenze
perchè non è da paese civile avere
situazioni di questo genere se
risolviamo queste emergenze
noi possiamo non solo salvare vite umane
non solo aumentare l'occupazione non
solo aumentare a fare crescita economica
e quindi aumentare il gettito lo stato
ma migliorare la vita di tutti
in italia abbiamo delle ricchezze
immense che dobbiamo valorizzare abbiamo
risorse storiche e culturali che ci
invidiano tutti nel mondo abbiamo opere
d'arte che riempono le sale ai nostri
musei e anche gli scandinavi perché
riusciamo ad esporle abbiamo risorse
ambientali e biodiversità che sono
uniche nel pianeta
abbiamo risorse umane e tecniche per cui
siamo in grado di fare qualsiasi tipo di
lavoro l'unica cosa che ci mancano sono
i soldi che si possono creare con un
click del computer
lo stato può creare sempre moneta
positiva nel pieno rispetto dei trattati
europei
ma cosa aspettiamo a farlo dobbiamo però
liberarsi dalle nostre convinzioni
radicate che impediscono di vedere la
realtà lo stato può sempre creare i
soldi per realizzare il benessere di
tutti i cittadini
questo è il vero fine dell'economia non
è la finanza la speculazione il profitto
l'obiettivo dell'economia è soddisfare i
bisogni individuali e collettivi
chiudiamo con un sorriso vi ricordate la
macchina sportiva bellissima e col
motore potentissimo ma non ci siamo
stufati di spingere la mano e poi non
con i tacchi a spillo
le macchine sono fatte per entrarci
dentro e guidarle dove vogliamo noi
ma per farlo dobbiamo avere il pieno di
benzina
lo stato può sempre creare moneta
pubblica e metterla nel sistema
economico attraverso la spesa pubblica
solo in questa maniera possiamo partire
decisi verso un futuro migliore e magari
fare da apripista per tutti gli altri
paesi del mondo moneta positiva digitale
mille miliardi per ripartire
se non ora quando grazie a tutti